προχώρησε με αυτή τη μέθωδο θεωρώ ότι δεν ήταν συνηθισμένοι κάποιες στο σίδιοκαλισμόν αυτός στην
αστυνομία ο ζητικαλισμούς αυτός στην αστυνομία έρχθεντοδύο ικάςσκωση και ήταν ένας τρόπος και για το
προηγούμενη ι γεσία να βοηθηθούν σε πάρα πολούς τομίς δυστυχώς δεν του επέλεξαν και δεν
ήταν θέμαν επιλογής ο συνδικαλισμός είναι θα μαν επιλογις του εργοδότη εναι δικαιώγμα του υπαλλήλου
ρά εσεί ανα εργοδό της ο φίλης να ακούς όλες τις συνδικαλιστικές φωνές δεν θεωρώ
ότι υπερευικά ορία γιατί των αμιλάς για τους αστυνομικούς από μόνο του είναι όριο είναι
σώματα ασφαλίας ε αστυνομική άρα έχουμε δύο επηλογίές ης ίσιοπας και δέχεσαι τα πάντα και
μένοι αστυνομία για ξεντα χρόνια εκεί που ήταν γιατί ι ένας και από τους λόγους
ποια αστηνομία δεν αναναδιοργανώθηκε τόσα χρόνια ήταν και ι έλλειψης συνδικαλισμού ή λες στα πράγματα
με τον νομαντους σύμφωνα με τον κόδικα τα ενοίκομιενδήμο και είναι ε δομένο αυτό αλλά
πολλές φορές δεν μπορείς παρανα μην τοποθέτησε με την αλήθεια πανωπολα ωςσγνόμονο το καλώς νόμενο
συμφέρον της αστυνομίας των αστυνομικώ και το πολίτη των αλλάζει για αισίας στην αστυνομία θεωρίσε
ότι αλλάζει ψηχολογία γίνεται κάτι καλύτερο ή απλά αλλάζουμε για ναλλάζουμε κάτι να μιλήσουμ γκαελίομε
από τος σερικούς όλους ότι αλλάζουμε προπονητή για να αλλάξει ψεχολογία τον παικτόν και να
αποήξουν πο δόσφερο είναι κάπως έτσι η πολιτεία είναι ο ιδιοκτήτης σε σεαγωγικά της αστυνομίας
και πολύ σροστατοεκι στέσι ο προμονητής από τον διορίζει ο ιδιοκτήδης έτσι μάλιστα και το
λέω μεταφορικά να εμπαραξιιθουμε αλλά των αλλάζεις συνεχώς αρχηγού ο υυαρχηγούς οι υπουργούς αλλάζεις απλά
που κάμις να δεν αλλάζεις στο περιεγόμενο το ανθρώπου του οργανισμού για αν αλλάξεις το
περιεργούμενο του υργανισμού θέλει το μές και πρέπει κάποια άνθρωποι να αναλάβουν αυτές στές τομές